welcome to oregon's bigfoot highway
[Music]
for decades maybe even longer people
have ventured into the mountains and
woods outside of portland to prove that
mankind is not alone in the woods
[Music]
okay so far mankind hasn't yet proved
that bigfoot exists
but for one club of long-time intrepid
bigfooters the truth is still out there
[Music]
and it's a great excuse to go camping
joe bilar believes in the existence of
bigfoot he wrote a book about it and he
claims to have had more than one
sighting in the second instance he was
from here to your cameraman from me
but i gotta say i don't think he was
quite as hairy
when people are skeptical
i tell them they're like ufos and ghosts
people see them but there's no widely
accepted scientific proof
joe's not alone he belongs to a group he
dubbed the clackama sasquatchians
clackamas for the county he lives in
we're actually in the heartland of
bigfoot activity and sasquatchians for
sasquatch
bigfoot and sasquatch
are synonymous terms in my group we're
bigfooters we just go out and do the job
we put ourselves out there we make a
bunch of noise play a bunch of music and
let the landscape know that we're there
and then later in the evening that's
when the strangest things would take
place
something's walking around your tent
it's like what what is that and that's
the excitement of it give you the ebg
bees
their backgrounds are varied
phds ex-military a retired science
teacher and a few engineers
and most have a specialty
my specialty is putting out offerings
if you come back and there's something
laying there where that apple was then
probably it was one of our barefoot
friends
i like to set up a camp in a comfortable
position i don't try to chase them down
i don't try to make a lot of noise maybe
they make a fry of some kind but is it a
sasquatch that's making these noises
we didn't see it we can't say that for
sure but it's a great hobby
it sounded squatchy i mean i don't feel
any scratchy vibes but well as far as my
specialty with joe's club is concerned i
just get a vibe and i can tell when
they're around
usually they put out vibe and i'm really
sensitive to that
this is squatchy for sure
[Music]
whether the squanchy vibes are flowing
is besides the point for the
sasquatchians the point is they're
together in their favorite place why do
i love doing this the flora and the
fauna
the butterflies
the night sky
it's all up there
people ask me if i believe in bigfoot
and i never give a definitive answer but
bigfoot is in my mind 10
of everything that we do to enjoy each
other's company
big footing helped me kick the cancer
spending four months in a hospital
getting chemotherapy was hell
and what made me get through that was
imagining me getting back up to the
woods and visit my friends
hopefully i'll get bigfoot sit around
the campfire with me one day
you